hey how's it going um I just had a
question about um modesty and dress in
like who's modesty mine or someone no no
just like in general because I'm I'm a
young guy and I'm Discerning marriage
and it's just to give you some
background I'm Roman Catholic so there's
not any real like clear-cut rules as far
as you have to do X Y and Z but I don't
know I just wanted to see I heard you
would like a month ago talk about it um
you were talking about how you know
there was you know women can wear pants
it's not like so cut and dry but at the
same time a lot of the dress we have
these days is you know 100 years ago
would have been considered scand so this
is the beauty of the scripture now let
me qualify I'm about to tell you before
I go on if you belong to a tradition
that's already defined what modesty is
then there's no need to ask me you
submit to the tradition because you
willfully have surrendered to that
church Authority right so the Catholic
Church tells you that women have to be
veiled on Sunday well women have to be
veiled on Sunday that's their tradition
and they expect those who are in good
faith with the church obey that so if
you have been convinced by your own
conscience as a spirit works by
convicting your conscience this is the
church that I need to be in that if they
tell you this is how you dress there's
no debate you don't need to ask anyone
else you get my point yeah yeah I think
the only confusion for me is that there
isn't really a clear Catholic position
verying opinions and you know all these
that was the second point now if the
church has not defined what M dress is
when we go to scripture the beauty of
scripture is it gives you principles at
times the Bible doesn't come out black
and white and tells you hey this is what
modest dress looks like or this is what
immod the Bible will give you
principles principles are applicable for
all times and generations until the Lord
returns so you find the principle and 1
Timothy
29-15 and 1 Peter 3 1-6 that a woman's
beauty doesn't come from braided hair or
jewelry it comes from her being humble
and modest and modest apparel but it
doesn't tell you what modest apparel is
that means god in his wisdom has allowed
us the freedom that if a particular
society says wearing pants is a sign of
a
man that's what men do then women don't
wear pants I'll give you an example
today yes we we look around us and woman
wear pants but not suits right mhm if
you see a woman wearing a suit suit
pants suit jacket and a tie you know
that's inappropriate because she's cross
the line because that's something that's
defined and limited to men correct right
so this is my point because the
principles are there those principles
can then be adapted in a particular time
and place and in light of that time and
place if wearing pants is not considered
men's wear but the society says women
can wear pants provided it's not tight
super tight skinny jeans where their
butt butttocks are sticking out or super
tight shirts where their breasts are
about to pop up then you cannot say
that's a modest dress yeah yeah the
interesting thing about that though is
that you know even something like a suit
you know give it another 20 years could
change to be women wear that as well so
well that ironically they have women
suit where instead of a pants and a
she'll wear like a dress but with a suit
jacket I've seen women wear that too
right yeah yeah this is the problem the
problem is is if a society is so
decadent and immoral and anti-god there
will be no limit to how much evil and
filth in a modesty it will tolerate but
then we have to then draw the line as a
church no no this is too much I don't
care if the society says this okay it's
not for example society says it's okay
for you go to the beach be topless and
wear a tight short and women to wear
g-strings and bikinis no I don't care if
the society says that's okay that's too
much skin too much
immodesty and you'll be a source of
stumbling block and cause people to sin
and lust in their hearts and I'm talking
about both men and women so when men go
out there bare chested wearing tight
shorts their skin sticking out you're
going to cause women and even gay men to
be tempted which I don't care about gay
men but you get my point right yeah
exactly that's where we cross the line
no I'm sorry no no no you can say this
is fine all you want too much skin too
much
cleavage you're you're basically
nude right you just got a g-string
that's covering one area but your butt
cheeks are sticking out same with the
men this is immodest this is showing too
much body part and this can be used of
the devil to cause people to lust and
burn and stumble and then men view women
as SE objects and vice versa in other
words when I see a woman half naked I'm
not thinking a Godly woman that I want
to take home to Mom I'm thinking she's a
piece of meat that I want to devour and
ravish and likewise a man who is showing
too much skin where he's got abs and
muscles the woman's thinking how I'd
like to jump in bed with him not how I
like to take him to Mommy and be married
to him and have children with him yeah
because you know you'll hear people say
that well my intentions were good I you
know I might have been wearing that but
my and I just like I never really bought
that argument either so yeah no say I
don't care what your intentions are
because you will judge you by your
fruits I don't have access to your heart
I only have access to your Deeds so let
your Deeds exemplify your intentions let
your Deeds reflect your intentions right
being half naked even even though your
intention is not to cause me to stumble
it's causing me to stumble you may say
I'm the Pervert all right God Purify Me
but until I'm cured don't be a source of
stumbling right that yeah makes sense to
me right yep it's like John bishu my
cousin who's like six4 when he takes off
his shirt you you want to throw up so
he's not causing women to stumble
because they lust for him he's causing
women to want to give up on the idea of
marriage because when they see something
so hit ugly they want to become nuns
leave being no no chance for any man to
marry any woman because he turns them
into
nuns I don't know if that answer the
question brother yes